adam every one of us has a reputation
you got a reputation i got a reputation
tyler's got a reputation david's got a
reputation george's got a reputation
president obama's got a reputation
trump's got a reputation biden's got a
reputation
there's not a single person in the world
that doesn't have a reputation now
here's the thing you know you'll hear a
lot of people say
well john maxwell once said reputation
is what john wooden once said reputation
is what other people think about you but
characters who you really are right all
this stuff to make ourselves feel better
but then the reality of it is if a bank
doesn't want to lend you 60 000 to buy a
car it's not because your character is
bad they don't care about your character
your credit score sucks right if the
bank doesn't get one to lend you a
million dollars to buy a house and your
credit score is 650 they don't care
about your ethnicity they don't care
about your last name they don't care all
they care about is your reputation
based on your credit is what you don't
pay things on time right
if there's anything
uh uh uh oh you want to be thinking
about going into a new year like i
remember it's me tom and mario
and we're at dallas and we're i'm
speaking at some insurance event okay
cody good guy he's putting an insurance
event together first time i ever met
david harris jr was there he sent me a
message so i'd love to hook up with you
so come on down we spent a good 45
minutes together in dallas yes you
remember this whole story when i'm over
there when we're at the 800
nation yes shout out by the way great
event they put together so when we're at
this country club uh me tom and mario
are preparing our notes
and i said what reputation did you have
when you were a kid okay
so and that bothered you that stayed
with you so tom tells me his okay mario
tells me his and i said let me give you
mine mine was two things my dad would
say patrick's lazy and number two was
they would compare me to an uncle of
mine guys his name was johnny love this
guy
six five good looking he was a physicist
he was a guy that would smoke the pipe
not pipe like crack pipe pipe pipe you
know what happened a little too much
though i don't know and he would smoke
the pipe and he would read these physics
books i mean who the hell does this that
was this guy got a clown
he liked good music he liked good
italian music but he had one reputation
guess what the reputation was
he would only do 70 of whatever project
he had he'd never completed he'd never
finished he would never finish it so it
was always
a reputation of wow he'll start things
he'll never in his life will ever finish
anything that was his reputation so i
because i was tall like him because i
was a math guy like him i would always
get compared to him and i would that was
my reputation
patrick's johnny they're the same thing
they're probably gonna this is what your
dad would say this is what my dad would
say and and you have to understand as a
kid i'm eight years old 10 years old
i know this is a guy that doesn't keep
his ward and finish the project but it's
brilliant wow i don't want to have that
reputation so i go to the military come
back in the military
work my ass off in my teens i make money
i always make my money i don't have
allowance i need i didn't come from a
family of allowance i've always made my
money anyways i get out of the military
i got the work ethic now
so at 25 26 years old i'm sitting there
and i'm asking myself so listen new
year's is coming up
what do you want your reputation to be
who do you want your reputation to be
okay your reputation is
you like to party your reputation as you
go to vegas every other weekend your
reputation is your bodybuilding your
reputation is you never want to have a
family your reputations you don't want
the responsibility of kids any of that
stuff everybody knew pat's now i don't
want to have any family i don't want to
do none of that stuff right
one day i sit down and i said if i have
a reputation i want my reputation to be
if pat says something's gonna happen
it's done you can bank it you can book
it
that's the reputation
you bring up the conversation about
people that always you know they say
well it's this it's this it's not me
it's my big bone it's this is that
anybody that's listening to this you
currently have a reputation amongst your
friends and families whether you like it
or not you have it at your work
environment right everybody thinks of
you in a certain way
if you want things to change you got to
kind of change some of the ways you're
living for your reputation to change by
the way some people say things like i
really don't give a [ __ ] about my
reputation now watch this let's play
this game
reputation when you think about trump
what do you think about david what's
trump reputation what's tyler's
reputation what what's trump's uh what's
trump's reputation tyler david what
would you say when you think about trump
what would you say is his reputation
bombastic what else egomaniacs does
anybody debate those two no no what else
uh arrogant what else disruption
disruption division
some people say he loves his country for
sure okay what else some people on the
other side of the womanizer 100 is that
debated no businessman businessman okay
would you say real estate mogul of
course that's his reputation now watch
this what's obama's reputation go
through obama's good bad ugly what's his
reputation community leader mood talker
no drama obama okay
communist okay
you know i'm going different sides what
uh what else uh good family man good
family man right what else um
face of the democratic party for sure
great now let's go to the next one tell
me how you got a nice lefty jump shot
does have a lefty jump shot actually how
about hillary clinton's reputation a
[ __ ]
would anybody debate that by the way i
think most people would say that she's
not that very likable on both sides by
the way yeah that's her reputation okay
smart brilliant nobody would debate that
nobody would debate not that likable
robotic connoisseur of pantsuits
okay
let's continue give me the reputation of
tom brady what's tom brady's winner
winner chicken dinner stud married to a
supermodel
just
gets fine wine better with age
like a hero like a hero what's jordan's
reputation the goat the goat the goat
okay what's kobe's reputation man like
mini goat mini goat okay now let's go to
give me a completely different person
let's go to hollywood what's tom
cruise's reputation
okay scientologist what else but what's
his reputation i mean um awesome
blockbuster movie guy what else you know
um
short what else
good looking what else he's kind of a
badass he doesn't know about it
bill o'reilly give me bill o'reilly's
reputation i mean that one that one
let's do it live yeah it's [ __ ] going
live
that was 30 years ago yeah and that's
still his reputation now what else what
else would you say is o'reilly's
reputation i mean i would say you know
outspoken okay uh josie smallett what's
his reputation that's uh
what's his reputation not so good he's a
hard worker truth teller hard worker and
a truth teller just a total
sham mockery shammachery yes divisive
willing to do anything to get right
higher liars
selfish okay fine what's joe rogan's
reputation um
yeah i mean the the face of new media
podcast spoken entertainment
entertainment everywhere podcast how
about asking what people are thinking
yes how about asking what people are
thinking says what's on your mind says
what's on your mind the every man the
one the every man the every man how
about the guy that said why shouldn't we
legalize marijuana okay how about a guy
that's the king of podcasts right that's
his reputation you're getting to the
point that no matter whether you like it
or not you've got a rep and if you
don't like it you got a chance you got
to change it
and if you don't like your reputation
and it bothers you well then do
something about it right
because you can't go to people and say
that's not the truth
that's not the truth
you have to understand when i hire
somebody
recently i had a guy that came on board
i brought him on board
and when i brought him on board all of a
sudden i got all these messages from his
former colleagues and people that do
business with them and his girls so it's
like hey you know about just so you know
i just want to show there's a reputation
with this person
i'm like oh whatever
and then one person second person third
person here's what you got to know about
papa papa i'm like listen i got it i've
been around business for a while i'll
make the decision for myself
you know what eventually happened what
everybody said is what happened right
we all have a reputation your reputation
precedes you yes so so you can try to
convince the world to say
no but that's not me listen that's your
rep yeah okay i remember i asked uh
sonata that worked with uh trump okay
she used to be a vp of about you
remember one of the biggest realtors
here in boca right you see her face
everywhere she's always on the real deal
she's always representing pretty blonde
lady pretty blonde lady but more
importantly brilliant smart incredible
husband marcus love these guys great
people right
i said so what was it like working with
trump i always want to know what trump
was like to work with so this guy would
show up at nine o'clock at night 10
o'clock at night and would walk around
saying are you making calls are you
working what are you doing
and she's like dude that's just lit
overbearing guess what if somebody ever
said trump drove his people hard would
you believe it 100 100 that's his
reputation do you think that bothers him
not at all not anything behind but what
i'm trying to tell you is that's the rep
he built and he wants so
adam what's your reputation let's go
through your reputation well as you're
saying this i had a conversation with a
friend
who
i hadn't seen in a while
and
he basically was like dude i really love
what you you're doing the whole save
that money stuff be smart with your
money and he starts telling adrian
mother he goes do you understand that
this guy was the brokest
just like penny-pinching friend we had
in high school
and
to your point
you either can just embrace that
reputation i don't care if you think or
do something that's right and that's
what i decided to do was change my rep
i was like the fact that i'm 10 years
later you know the money guy save that
money be smart with your money invest
was so far from who i was as a teenager
it wasn't even funny so
you know everyone has the opportunity to
change who they are nothing is there's
no permission about that
yeah and i'm getting goosebumps by the
way because i'm going to circle back to
what was your uncle who didn't finish
when he started yeah because as you were
telling this story and you and i asked
if that was your dad you know your dad
pulled me aside
at
the the holiday party we had at your
house do you remember i was talking to
you i was talking to your dad for an
hour yeah he pulled him you were like
why did you interrupt me me and my
mother were talking i love that guy
um
because a lot of the qualities he has
the quality were qualities my dad didn't
have whatever he's just very wise men
you could tell
and he pulled me into his room his
bedroom and he showed me all the
the the quilts that he had sewed
you know what i'm talking about the
covers of course and there was a covered
one a new york city one and uh
uh a texas one like you it's like ten of
them
right and and i go why are you showing
me this he goes this is the lesson and
and dylan and tico are there and he goes
you have to finish what you started
you have to finish what you started
and and so that's why i asked if this is
what he told what your reputation was
about your uncle they did 70
and and and dylan goes how long did that
take
right i love that kid and he goes it
doesn't matter
i started it i finished it it doesn't
matter how long it took the fact is that
i did it
he's so inc the size of a bet and he's
peeling them off one more self-taught by
the way yeah that's incredible
and he showed me what he did with the
chess piece and the chairs we should
have him on his podcast we should have
on the podcast he'd be amazing but
he was like
and he says time is a thief
time is a thief i'll never forget this
conversation
and he said um
[Music]
basically about procrastination i go
what's the difference between successful
people and unsuccessful people and he
goes i have an answer for you he goes
the unsuccessful people will say i'll do
it tomorrow
uh the
i'll do it tomorrow
he said no you do it now
you do it now
we're at a christmas party i'm alone
with your dad for an hour learning
embracing hearing what he's got going on
so it's not a shock to me that
the the stories that you tell about your
family and the lessons and how you
changed your reputation
probably came from your dad i would
assume oh there's no question about it
yeah there's but
again going back to it
i did not want that to be my reputation
i'm completely okay with certain things
being my my reputation patrick's a
driver he's going to drive you this he's
going to do this he's going to do that
no one's ever going to say you're going
to outwork pat it's just not going to
happen so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]